we're joined now by cbs news chief
political analyst john dickerson john
welcome uh the debt ceiling issue could
be catastrophic for democrats not
passing anything i think would be
catastrophic uh what's going on with
these bills
well you've got a four car pileup i mean
you've got the bills to keep the
government open then the bill and the
debt ceiling then you've got the bill in
the infrastructure and then you've got
the bill on social spending all coming
up at the same time
what's happening last night that had
everybody there late into the night and
that's been on pause is a debate within
the democratic party the other two are
debates within republicans and democrats
but this is a debate within the
democratic party about the priorities of
the democratic party which makes it a
little bit different we're used to
debates in washington where depending on
the jersey you wear and the team you're
on it seems all precooked this is a
debate within a party everybody's
wearing the same jersey it's a family
debate and this is what happens with
legislation it's messy there are serious
things at stake and that sometimes looks
real messy and we're all watching the
messiness but as you point out it is
different because there is a fracture
within the democratic party on this it
was a self-imposed deadline last night
what actually happens where does this go
well
self-imposed deadlines are important
nothing focuses the mind like a hanging
true so um
what you have is this is reality hitting
it was never going to be the case in a
democratic party where you have one
faction where in their districts they
haven't voted for a republican since
1980 and then you got joe manchin who
comes from west virginia not a single
county in west virginia has voted for a
democrat since 2008 so that's a big
coalition tiny little margins there's
always going to be a fight and that
fight is happening right now and that's
what's happening they're trying to
figure out with these razor thin margins
how to get everybody to agree you say
the shutdown isn't normal sausage making
when passing bills in congress how is
this different well you know i always
wonder if the sausage making people want
to come in and say hey wait a minute
we're doing much more clearly than this
the reason this is different is because
it is a family fight right legislation
is supposed to be messy we do the messy
business of legislation so we don't
fight each other with our fists and so
what's happening here is it's a debate
you know the progressives are saying
they're real human beings at the end of
this thing there are women who aren't
going to get back into the workforce
unless they get somebody to take care of
their kids there's somebody who has an
opportunity to go to college who can't
afford it there are real things that we
fought for and put you in office for
real lives at the end of this yep and
then the other side is saying well yes
but you can't do you know can't cost
this much because that's gonna hurt real
lives too the infrastructure bill might
create two million jobs so there are
real things at issue here so when people
look at this yes it looks messy but it's
the messy push and pull of people trying
to figure out how to get the best ideas
out of the limited political space they
have and that's what the whole system
was set up sound like you like it john i
know it was the same people at home are
so frustrated
well it's frustrating sure because you
want stuff to happen quickly but this is
different than the normal frustration
right and new frustration it's a
different but it's also the frustration
that was built into the system that it's
going to be messy and long now if it
gets to nothing and they get nowhere
then then people have uh frustration one
of the papers said it was a humiliation
for the president we're a couple of
stops away from humiliation
if they pass something today that's a
pretty short humiliation and you know
you get you get progress and especially
if you pass something memories are very
short very very short john thank you
good to see you